(mechanism locking)
(soft reminiscent piano music)
- There is no manual
on how to be a lampist.
It takes many, many years to
learn all the facets of the job.
At the peak of the
profession there were about
800 lampists nationally.
And I am, really, one of the
last people who are doing it.
(soft reminiscent piano music)
My name is Jim Woodward,
and I am a lampist.
That's what I do.
(high-pitched bells chiming mystically)
Well, a lampist is the specialist
who works with lighthouse lenses.
Maintenance of them, moving of them,
disassembly, reassembly,
just about everything there is to do.
This one, I believe, is an impact break.
When I do an initial
inspection of the lens,
I will go over every prism
and check every joint.
You literally tap.
And then I will do an audio check
of every prism in the lens.
You can almost play a tune.
It requires infinite patience.
Beautiful.
Just beautiful.
The lampist profession started about 1850.
So indeed, the lampists'
work was very important
because without the lenses being
completely operational, they were useless.
So the lampist kept the lenses working,
and the lighthouse keeper
kept them lit every night.
So, together, they kept the sailors safe.
As technology was developed,
the classical Fresnel
lens started to decline,
and it didn't require
the services of lampists.
It would be a shame to
let the profession die
because, in the process, eventually,
the lenses themselves will die.
Today, people drive
around the country looking
at lighthouses and think nothing of it.
I almost feel a mystical kind of feeling
when I get near, near a lighthouse.
I have a real connection to it,
and I feel extremely
fortunate to have had a life,
52 years now, of working with lenses.
To me, it’s just the most
amazing thing in the world.